This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. While I was doing interviews to promote the book, someone asked me, what is your favorite way to experience the city? The answer is walking. I love to walk. If you have nothing to do, take a walk. If you are overwhelmed with things to do. Also, take a walk.
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。当我在为新书做宣传采访时，有人问我：“你体验城市最喜欢的方式是什么？”答案是步行。我喜欢走路。如果你没事可做，去散步吧。如果你被成堆的事物压得喘不过气来。也去散步吧。
We've been working so hard on the book release and in many series that were launching in December that we're gonna take a walk with our friends at Pop Up magazine. They are a live magazine show created to be performed on stage in front of a live audience. Pop Up is this really beautiful groundbreaking leap forward in journalism, but since there are no theater shows happening right now,
我们为了新书的发布以及12月即将推出的许多系列节目一直在努力工作，所以我们要和Pop Up杂志的朋友们一起去散步。他们是一个现场杂志秀，专为在现场观众面前的舞台上表演而创作。Pop Up是新闻界真正美丽、具有突破性的一大飞跃，但由于目前没有剧院演出，
they've been making stories to enjoy at home. And this one was so delightful and so of my alley. I just wanted this all to do it together. So let me introduce you to my friend, Haley. Hi, this is Haley Hall from Popup Magazine. And I'm going to take you on a walk. If you need a second to get ready, press pause. Grab some headphones, don't forget your keys and your mask, then come back and we'll head out.
他们一直在制作适合在家欣赏的故事。这个故事太美妙了，完全符合我的风格。我只想让大家一起来听。所以我向大家介绍我的朋友海莉。嗨，我是Pop Up杂志的海莉·霍尔。我将带你去散步。如果你需要几秒钟准备一下，请按暂停。拿上耳机，别忘了钥匙和口罩，然后回来，我们这就出发。
You good? All right, let's go. There are a million ways to walk in this world. So whatever walking means to you, in this moment, do that. It could be going on a walk in your mind while laying on the couch. That's totally fine. It really is. But if you're up for it, go outside. If you're like me, maybe you found yourself taking more walks recently. I don't really
准备好了吗？好的，我们走吧。在这个世界上有成百万种走路的方式。所以，无论散步对你意味着什么，在此刻，就那样去做。它可以是躺在沙发上时在脑海里进行的漫步。那完全没问题。真的可以。但如果你准备好了，就去户外吧。如果你跟我一样，也许你发现自己最近散步的次数变多了。我其实
have anywhere to go, but I really need to get out of the house. So I walk. For today's walk, you don't need a destination. And that's kind of the point. All you need to do is breathe and move forward. As you hear stories from some of our friends about what walking means to them. Okay? Here we go. I'm Anna Sail and I host the podcast Death, Sex, and Money. I'm Anna Sale and I host the podcast Death, Sex, and Money. The best solo walks I can remember are like, before when I was like single living in New York City,
无处可去，但我真的很需要离开家。所以我走路。今天的散步，你不需要目的地。这正是关键所在。你只需要呼吸并向前迈进，同时聆听我们的一些朋友讲述散步对他们的意义。好吗？我们走吧。我是安娜·塞尔，我是播客《死亡、性和金钱》的主持人。我是安娜·赛尔，我是播客《死亡、性和金钱》的主持人。我能记住的最佳独自散步经历，比如以前我还是个单身汉、住在纽约市的时候，
you start at Union Square in Manhattan and you've discovered that you don't have much to do in a day and you just like start walking. And then you like look up the movie times. And then you like realize you could go to a movie and you're gonna walk to Dwayne Reed ahead of time and get a big leader of club soda and trail mix and maybe a little bit of chocolate,
你从曼哈顿的联合广场出发，发现自己一天也没什么事可做，于是你就像这样开始走路。然后你查了查电影场次。接着你意识到你可以去看场电影，于是你打算提前走到Dwayne Reed药妆店，买一大升苏打水、混合干果，或许还有一点巧克力，
and stuff in your purse. Man, to spend a day that way, I know, I saw only two little kids, and a couple of the like to just walk with no destination seems so luxurious. I also want to give a special shout out to the walking in New York City while crying on a cell phone walk. At a certain point you're like, I don't care. I don't care who's seeing me, who's walking past me. Like, I liked having this way of creating my own little personal
塞进你的钱包里。天哪，以这种方式度过一天，我知道，我只看到两个小孩子，还有几个像这样漫无目的地散步的人，显得太奢侈了。我还要特别致敬一种散步方式，那就是在纽约一边哭一边用手机打电话的散步。到了某个时刻，你会想：我不在乎。我不在乎谁在看我，谁从我身边走过。就像，我喜欢在曼哈顿繁华的街道上用这种方式创造我自己的小天地，
crying space on the busy streets of Manhattan. on the busy streets of Manhattan. I cried my first 90 days, and I wanted to quit. But, you know, seeing the people faces when we're out there walking and the smiles on their face when they see us coming. To me, that made my postal career just fascinating. I'm Kelly Mathon. I'm a male carrier at the Indytrate Michigan out of Wrightmore station. I have been a male carrier for 26 years now. My route I walked between 8 to
一个专属于我的哭泣空间。在我送信的前90天里，我一直在哭，甚至想过辞职。但是，你知道的，看到我们走在路上时人们脸上的表情，看到他们看到我们到来时脸上的微笑。对我来说，这让我的邮政职业生涯变得如此迷人。我是凯莉·马松。我是密歇根州印第安特雷特怀特莫尔站的一名邮递员。我当邮递员已经26年了。我的路线每天步行大约8到
10 miles a day. I can handle the cold. It's just when the snow the first snow fall. It looks so beautiful when you first going out there. It's like, oh, it looks so pretty until you get out there and have to start walking and people don't shovel
10英里。我能忍受寒冷。只是当雪——第一场雪降临时。刚出门时看起来太美了。就像是，哦，看起来真漂亮，直到你真正走出门开始步行，而人们却没有铲雪，
you slipping the slide and down the street. And I'm not embarrassed to say it's been a few times I had to sit on the steps to get down off the porch Yeah, cuz I do not want to fall in it's been times I have fallen down some stuff and it wasn't cute The good things about being on the route As long as I've been on theirs knowing everyone that they look out for me and Since the pandemic one of my customers made a poster sign. And he put on their head Kelly Americans are awesome.
导致你在街上滑倒。而且我并不不好意思承认，有好几次我不得不坐在台阶上才能从门廊下来，因为我真的不想摔倒。确实有好几次我在台阶上摔倒过，那样子可真不好看。在邮递路线工作的好处是，既然我在那儿待了这么久，每个人都认识我，他们会关照我。自从疫情爆发以来，我的一位顾客做了一个标语牌。他把牌子举在头上写着：“凯莉，美国人太棒了。”
And so are you. Thank you. And I was walking up to the house because I had my head down getting the mail ready. And when I looked up, it made me cry. And I knocked on the door. He came to the door, and I was like, that's so sweet of you to put that out there. He's like, I just want to let you know you are awesome carrier.
“你也是。谢谢你。”当我正朝那栋房子走去时，因为我正低着头整理邮件。当我抬起头时，我感动得哭了。我敲了敲门。他走到门口，我说：“你把这个挂出来太贴心了。”他说：“我只是想让你知道，你是一位出色的邮递员。”
You always look out for us because when he gets medicine, I walk to the side door. I knock on the door, him and his wife come and get it. I don't leave it on the front porch. I don't want anyone to take it. Not under my watch. Hahaha. Lulu Miller is a radio producer and author of the book Why Fish Don't Exist. So this is the exercise that my wonderful sister Alexa Rose Miller told me about.
“你总是照顾我们。”因为当他有药送到时，我会走到侧门。我敲敲门，他和妻子会出来拿。我不会把它留在前门廊。我不希望任何人拿走它。在我眼皮底下绝对不行。哈哈哈哈。露露·米勒是广播制作人兼《为什么鱼不存在》一书的作者。所以这是我出色的姐姐阿勒克萨·罗斯·米勒告诉我的一个练习。
I'm joined here by my co-host. My 22 month old son. We're going on a walk. In the surprisingly beautiful Indiana dunes. This is a mob of this. And the exercise is this. As you walk, look for one of each of every color of the rainbow. And pick it up, take it home with you.
我的联合主持人也加入了我的行列。我22个月大的儿子。我们要去散步。在出人意料美丽的印第安纳沙丘。这是一个暴民。这个练习是这样的。当你散步时，寻找彩虹中每种颜色的各一样东西。把它捡起来，带回家。
First thing, got a piece of green grass and I will keep you posted as we go. My name is Dan Brune. I'm a bush walker and photographer from Tasmania. Tasmania is an island bottom of Australia. Australia of course is a continent at the bottom of the world, so I live under down under. It has many of the most mountainous islands on earth, and so every walk you go on your start close to the ocean and then you just walk up, it will really quick. But as you go up, you traverse different vegetation layers and you go through curtains and curtains and curtains. So you might start in coastal scrub with this
第一样东西，拿到了一片绿草，我们边走边向大家汇报。我叫丹·布伦。我是来自塔斯马尼亚的丛林步行者和摄影师。塔斯马尼亚是澳大利亚底部的一个岛屿。澳大利亚当然是位于世界底部的洲，所以我住在所谓的“世界尽头下方”。它拥有地球上许多最山峦起伏的岛屿，所以你每次散步都是从靠近海洋的地方开始，然后你只要往上走，路程就会变得非常快。但当你往上走时，你会穿过不同的植被层，你会穿过一层又一层又一层的树林。所以你可能从海岸灌木丛开始，这里有
hundered rimer of the pit soils and you'll climb up into a deeper forest along a creek line and it will be rainforest. A temperate rainforest. The air is cold in your face. It's filled with every type of grain from the muscles and the liplines to the rainforest trees and the metals of the sassupras. And as you go through these various vegetation layers, finally, finally, finally, you'll just see sky.
贫瘠土壤上长出的矮小植物，然后你会沿着小溪攀登到更深的森林，那里将是雨林。温带雨林。冰冷的空气扑面而来。这里充满了各种各样的绿色植物，从苔藓和攀缘植物到雨林树木和黄杨木。当你穿过这些不同的植被层时，最终，最终，最终，你只会看到天空。
And everything becomes small. Everything becomes intricate and tiny and detailed. And that's what it is when you're in the Alfonso of Tasmania. Hi, I'm Jenny Slate. I'm an actor, comedian and writer. So when I came back to Massachusetts this year, there just wasn't anyone around and people don't tell you and you never remember even if you're like me and you grew up here that March is just February And it's cold and it's very dark, but I really really need to walk every day and I need I guess what I need is to be able to greet someone or something and so in the woods by our house is a pet cemetery and I started to bundle up and go for the short walk out to the pet cemetery to say hello to the buried pets. There's cheeky and booby, and Nedzie.
一切都变小了。一切都变得精巧、细微而充满细节。这就是当你身处塔斯马尼亚的阿尔丰索时的感受。嗨，我是珍妮·斯蕾特。我是一名演员、喜剧演员和作家。所以当我今年回到马萨诸塞州时，周围根本没人，人们不会告诉你，而你永远不会记得，哪怕你像我一样在这里长大，三月其实就是二月。
I say their names and Sometimes I just like sort of crew at them and say like hello sweethearts and I sort of imagine like You know transparent little ghost dogs like nipping at my heels I could imagine that they felt found again. And what's happening here, of course, is a projection. And that I just want to be also found. I'm John Sterl. I'm a resident in the Southern Valley, West Minister of Canterbury, continuing care retirement community.
而且天气很冷，天黑得很早，但我真的真的很需要每天散步，我需要——我想我需要的是能够向某人或某物打个招呼，所以在我们房子旁边的树林里有一个宠物墓场，我开始裹紧衣服，进行这趟简短的散步，走到宠物墓场去和那些被埋葬的宠物们打招呼。有奇奇、布比和内德齐。
And I made E1. I do go for walks every day. I've gotten to the point that I like to walk 10 miles. I have downloaded the United States Air Force band Susan Marches and I'll march instead of walking and I've been knowing to pick up a sticker too and pretend I'm a drum major because I have been a drum major in the past but I only do that after 10 o'clock a night after all the other residents go to bed. And then if I get bored with the marches and I have polka accordion music on and I'll start dancing my way around instead of walking or marching. Oh my god, awesome contender for bright orange.
我念出它们的名字，有时我只是冲它们嘟囔，说些像“嗨，小宝贝们”这样的话，我甚至能想象出……你知道的，那种透明的小幽灵狗在我的脚后跟边嬉戏啃咬。我能想象它们觉得自己被找到了。而这里正在发生的事情，当然是一种投射。我也只是想被找到而已。我是约翰·斯托尔。我是坎特伯雷威斯敏斯特南方谷的居民，这是一个持续护理退休社区。
Tasty little like a racer size neon orange mushrooms. Okay, Jude vetoes. I think I'm gonna leave them where they are because they look happy, but I'll take a picture. Oh, Jude's huge. Look. This sleeve, oh, my mom needs this sleeve has a little everything. Right on the outside, yellow and green on the inside. If you squint at it, it's kind of orange. It's a contender for my film. I have a German Shepherd's Sing I Dog named Milo. He's my walking buddy and we walked all over the world. He's my walking buddy and we walked all over the world.
而我做到了。我每天都去散步。我已经养成了步行10英里的习惯。我下载了美国空军乐队的苏萨进行曲，我行军而不是散步，我甚至偶尔会拿起一根指挥棒，假装自己是个乐队指挥，因为我过去曾当过乐队指挥，但我只在晚上10点以后、所有其他居民都上床睡觉之后才这么做。然后，如果我对进行曲感到厌倦了，我就会放手风琴波尔卡音乐，开始边跳舞边四处转悠，而不是走路或行军。哦，天哪，这是亮橙色的绝佳候选者。
My name is Haven Germa, I'm the disability rates advocate. When I walk with Milo, I'm holding his harness. His harness wraps around his middle and his front. So when he turns to the left, to the right, I can feel it. Most people assume that the guide dog is deciding where we go. Sometimes he does try to make those decisions. So if he is walking and he sees a squirrel, his ears perk up. I feel it in his body.
看起来像是美味的霓虹橙色小蘑菇。好吧，朱德否决了。我想我还是让它们留在原地吧，因为它们看起来很开心，但我会拍张照片。哦，朱德太棒了。看。这根绳索，哦，我妈妈需要这个，这根绳索什么都有。外面是黄色，里面是绿色。如果你眯起眼睛看，它有点像橙色。这是我拍摄的候选对象。我有一只名叫米洛的德国牧羊犬导盲犬。他是我的散步搭档，我们一起走遍了全世界。他是我的散步搭档，我们一起走遍了全世界。
His attention is distracted. And I make the choice to tell him, no, keep going. Move past it. It's kind of like a ballroom dance. We're constantly connected. I'm constantly adjusting my movements to mirror his movements so that we can keep moving
我叫海文·杰马，我是残疾人权利倡导者。当我跟米洛一起散步时，我抓着他的挽具。他的挽具缠绕在他的腰部和前胸。所以当他向左转、向右转时，我都能感觉得到。大多数人以为是导盲犬在决定我们去哪里。有时他的确会试图做出那些决定。所以如果他在走路时看到一只松鼠，他的耳朵会竖起来。我能从他的身体上感测到。
across the floor. Ballroom is a culture of competitive artists or artistic competitors. That's how I see it. And it was pioneered by Black and Latina transgender women who basically created a space for LGBTQ youth of color to compete in different categories for cash prizes. So my name is Sydney Blue, AKA Sid extravaganza. I remember the first time I walked realness as a category. Realness actually refers to when somebody
他的注意力被分散了。而我做出了选择，告诉他：“不，继续走。走过去。”这有点像交谊舞。我们始终保持着连接。我不断调整自己的动作来配合他的动作，这样我们才能继续在舞池中穿行。
of a particular gender identity puts on a performance of an archetype of another. On the flyer, it said, butch, realness. And I was like, ooh, what's that? And so I asked my house mother at the time, and she was like, sit, this is your category. All you have to do is you have to present as a cisgendered man, a straight man.
舞池是竞技艺术家或艺术竞争者的文化。这就是我眼中的它。它由黑人和拉丁裔跨性别女性开创，她们基本上为有色人种的LGBTQ青少年创造了一个空间，让他们可以在不同的类别中争夺现金奖。所以我的名字叫悉尼·布鲁，也就是“极致悉尼”。我还记得我第一次参加“本色”走秀比赛时的情景。“本色”实际上指的是某人
And so, you know, I had to look ready, the category was coming up. I was so nervous, cause I'd never walked this category before. And I was just like, oh man, a man, you know, I'm gonna pull this off, oh gosh. And then I remember they called out the category, the commentator called it out, okay, anybody walking,
所以，你知道，我必须准备好，这个组别要开始了。我非常紧张，因为我以前从未走过这个组别。我当时就想，天哪，老兄，你知道，我要成功了，天哪。然后我记得他们喊出了这个组别，解说员喊出来了，好吧，任何人都可以走，
10, 9, 8, 7, 6, nobody's coming out, 5, 4, and then finally I was like, all right, I'm gonna do it. And let me tell you, the crowd went... Flannan! Forming people got out of their seats. Oh my God, it was like 10s, 10s, 10s, 10s, 10s across the board.
10，9，8，7，6，没人出来，5，4，然后我终于想，好吧，我要上了。我跟你说，全场都……天哪！大家纷纷离开座位。噢天哪，简直是全场满分，全场满分！
Like people were just living for me. And it was incredible. I'd never experienced anything like that. And for me, especially being somebody who was maligned for my masculinity as a woman, for being told that I should look a certain way, sit a certain way, have my hair a certain way, all this kind of stuff, and then getting to that point
就像人们都在为我欢呼。这太不可思议了。我从未经历过这样的事。对我来说，尤其是作为一个曾因身为女性却被指责缺乏女性特质而饱受诟病的人，曾有人对我说我应该看起来是什么样、坐着是什么样、头发应该是什么样，诸如此类，然后到了我生命中的那个时刻
in my life where I could be in a room of my peers and completely celebrated for who I was, it was just like the greatest feeling in the world. I'm Alice Sheppard, Dancer and writer. So I'm a wheelchair user. I encounter the world from the point of view of wheeling. I use the word walk, a fair amount that often makes people uncomfortable. often makes people uncomfortable. Some of the most important walks that I have ever had
我能在一群同伴中，因为真实的自我而受到彻底的庆祝，那种感觉简直是世上最棒的。我是爱丽丝·谢泼德（Alice Sheppard），舞者兼作家。我是一名轮椅使用者。我从轮椅的角度体验这个世界。我相当频繁地使用“走”这个词，这常常让人感到不舒服。这常常让人感到不舒服。我经历过的一些最重要的步行
are with other wheelchair users. There's a moment where we sink strokes. There's something about the rhythm of pushing a chair and the sounds that our wheels make. The fact that we are connected in this way is sometimes it's really sexy sometimes it's really just piece-bringing sometimes it's joyous this kind of walking this is community walking My name is Aaron Reese. I'm a journalist and I live in Mexico City. What's cool about Mexico City is walking is fascinating all the time. There's so much happening on the street that it's hard to be bored when you're walking. Whether you're getting your shoes fixed
是和其他轮椅使用者在一起。那一刻我们的步伐合拍。推动椅子的节奏以及我们的轮子发出的声音有一种奇妙的感觉。我们以这种方式相连，有时这真的很性感，有时这真的只是带来平静，有时这充满欢乐，这种步行，这就是社区步行。我叫阿伦·里斯（Aaron Reese）。我是一名记者，住在墨西哥城。墨西哥城最酷的地方在于，步行总是那么迷人。街上发生的事情太多了，以至于你走路时很难感到无聊。无论你是去修鞋
or you're getting a piece of clothes mended or you're buying a taco, it's all happening like on the sidewalk and oftentimes in the street. But there's a certain subset of mobile street vendors that have sounds to alert people as to their presence. And so if you hear enormous steam whistle, you know that the sweet potato salesman is outside and you have 10 minutes to catch him before you have to jog and catch him on the block.
还是去补一件衣服，或者买个塔可卷饼，这一切都发生在人行道上，而且经常就在街道上。但是有一类移动街头小贩，他们有特定的声音来提醒人们他们的存在。所以如果你听到巨大的蒸汽哨声，你就知道烤红薯小贩在外面，你只有10分钟的时间去追上他，否则你就得跑步去街区追他。
And as you look around, the street is sort of coming alive. You see a guy pop his head up the window and yell down like, hey wait for me, I'll be there in a second. People pull pull over people jog to catch up And then there's the knife sharpener guy and his sound is probably my favorite because it's like a little musical performance. He has a pamphlet and all the knife sharpeners have pamphlets that play these different chord progressions, but each one has its own little style. And you hear it coming, you know, like Doppler Effect style, and you're like, okay, I'm pretty sure he's coming from the left. And you're like, no, no, he's coming from the right.
当你环顾四周，街道仿佛苏醒了。你看到一个人把头探出窗外大喊，嘿，等等我，我马上就到。人们停下来，人们慢跑着赶上。然后是磨刀人的声音，这大概是我最喜欢的，因为它就像一首小型的音乐演奏。他有一张传单，所有的磨刀人都有传单，上面播放着这些不同的和弦进行，但每个人都有自己的小风格。你听到它由远及近，你知道的，就像多普勒效应一样，你会想，好吧，我确信他是从左边来的。然后你会想，不对，不对，他是从右边来的。
And you like have to go, you know, wind your way through the neighborhood, following your ear to catch the guy. Our walk continues even even into space. After this. Come on, forest. Show me blue and purple. Oh, man, I just got my purple. I got my purple.
你必须去，你知道的，在街区里蜿蜒前行，顺着声音去追那个人。我们的步行还在继续，甚至延伸到了太空。稍后继续。来吧，森林。向我展示蓝色和紫色。天哪，我刚刚找到了紫色。我找到紫色了。
I got my purple. It's a little leaf. It's a gorgeous, true freaking purple. Okay, all I have to do now is blue. And suddenly I feel the weight of a large head on one of my neck for the brain, which is the feeling of my son falling asleep in this hiking backpack sick of my musings upon the colors of the forest there. My name is Sam Day. I'm a comedian and a writer for Saturday Night Live. When I was younger, I used to hang out with my older cousin.
我找到紫色了。那是一片小叶子。是一种华丽、纯正的紫色。好的，我现在要找的只有蓝色了。突然，我感觉到一个沉重的脑袋压在我的颈部，那是我的大脑感受，其实是我儿子在这个远足背包里睡着了，他已经厌烦了我对森林颜色的沉思。我叫萨姆·戴（Sam Day）。我是一名喜剧演员，也是《周六夜现场》的编剧。当我年轻的时候，我经常和我较大的表哥一起玩。
His name is Gerald. And he lived in this place in Boston called The Stop In or The Bad Bay. They had built this housing development in The Bad Bay. But the rest of The Bad Bay was full of rich people. And it's where all the rich shops were. You could really just go out and walk around and cause mischief for a lack of a better word. We used to buy all these joke-gag things from the joke shop downtown,
他叫杰拉尔德（Gerald）。他住在波士顿一个叫“车站”或“湾区”的地方。他们在湾区建了这个住宅区。但湾区的其余部分到处都是富人。那是所有昂贵商店所在的地方。你真的可以出去走走，用现在的话说就是去恶作剧。我们过去常常从市中心的玩笑店买所有这些整蛊玩具，
so like a dollar snatcher and like stinky bombs and like things that make fart noises. All this goofy stuff. And we would take it down Newberry Street and trick people, we'd put the dollar statue or down to watch people try to pick it up and snatch the dollar and laugh. Or while someone was sitting outside of Restaurant, we hit the fart thing and make it sound like they farted
比如美元夹子、臭气弹还有制造放屁声音的东西。所有这些滑稽的东西。我们会把它带到纽伯里街（Newberry Street）去捉弄人，我们放下美元夹子，看着人们试图去捡它，然后一把抓过美元并大笑。或者当有人坐在餐厅外面时，我们按下放屁的玩具，让它听起来像是他们放了个屁
and then run off and just like, goofy little silly kid stuff. and just like goofy little silly and can't stop. You're so aware when you're growing up in poverty, that like all this stuff around you is not for you. And like, they're not considering you in any of this. And so it was a way for us to kind of push back against the thing by just going and being like, well, we could be in here too, you know. My name is Antoine Williams and I'm the co-creator and the sound designer for
然后跑开，就像那种古怪的小傻瓜蛋一样。就像那种滑稽的小傻瓜，停不下来。你在贫困中长大时，会深深地意识到，周围的所有东西都不是为你准备的。而且，他们根本不会在任何事情上考虑你。所以这是我们通过走出去并表现得像“我们也可以在这里，你知道吗”来反抗这种现状的一种方式。我叫安托万·威廉姆斯（Antoine Williams），我是热门播客《Ear Hustle》的联合创作者兼声音设计。
the hip podcast, Ear Hustle. I grew up in prison. I spent my late teens and all of my 20s inside of California's prisons and the way that we protest on the inside is completely opposite from how people protest on the outside. The way that we protest on the inside is to sit down. So upon my release I was able to join Black Lives Matter protest and rallies and marches for the equality and the equity of disenfranchised people. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, out there. I was out there, out there, out there. In the entire march, I was silent. And just every step that I took, I felt good. I was stepping with intention.
我在监狱里长大。我的青少年时期和整个20多岁都在加利福尼亚的监狱里度过，我们在里面的抗议方式与外面的人完全相反。我们在里面的抗议方式是坐下。因此，在我获释后，我能够加入“黑人的命也是命”的抗议、集会和游行，为被剥夺权利的人争取平等和公平。不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，南无阿姨。我在那里，我在那里，我在那里，我在那里。在整个游行过程中，我一直保持沉默。我迈出的每一步，我都感觉很好。我是带着意图在迈步。
Like I can walk for however long the people want to walk. Yeah! I climbed Machille, Majaro on Veterans Day 2015. My name is Julian Torres, I'm a former sergeant in the United States Marine Corps. I got hurt in 2013. I'm left below the knee amputation right above the knee amputation. The idea of Kilimanjaro really came from, I wanted to see what kind of capabilities I had post like missing half my body. I needed to know where I landed on the spectrum of like liability and an asset. But it was my first time walking through mud. That was like ankle deep. Walking through that was like walking on the slip and slide. You know what I mean?
就像人们想走多久，我就可以走多久。耶！我在2015年退伍军人节那天登上了乞力马扎罗山。我叫朱利安·托雷斯（Julian Torres），我是美国海军陆战队的前中士。我在2013年受伤。我的左腿膝盖以下截肢，右腿膝盖以上截肢。攀登乞力马扎罗山的念头其实源于，我想看看在失去半个身体之后，我还有什么样能力。我想知道我在累赘和资产之间的天平上落在哪里。但这是我第一次在泥地里行走。那泥没脚踝深。在里面走就像在滑水道上行走一样。你知道我的意思吗？
It's just like, when I would fall, one or two things happened, like, nothing. If nothing happened, if I just fell, I met the ground, gave it a hug, and then I got back up, or a part of my legs would break. And they did break. And so, like on day two, I guess you would say where my ankle was, my right ankle, right? Bolt had broken off, so like every three or four steps I would have to stop and then turn my foot because it would pivot and my toes would be facing like my back.
就像，当我摔倒时，会发生一两件事，比如，什么都没发生。如果什么都没发生，如果我只是摔倒了，我接触了地面，给它一个拥抱，然后我站了起来，或者我腿的一部分会断掉。它们确实断了。所以，就像在第二天，我想可以说是在我脚踝的地方，我的右脚踝，对吧？螺栓断了，所以每走三四步我就得停下来，然后转动我的脚，因为它会转动，我的脚趾会朝向我的后背。
But I'm going to make it to the moon if I have to crawl. I don't think I walked away not gonna fake it. Perfect blue. Blue were then blue, blue, blue, blue, blue, blue, blue, blue, blue, not gonna fake it. Perfect these. We have completed. Right now. I'm Caroline Shaw. I'm a musician. And I like to walk. I grew up with all these cassette tapes of the lives of the great composers, which my mom had a box of and she kept in our minivan and you know, pick one out and put it in and
但就算必须爬行，我也要去月亮。我不认为我走开时不会假装。完美的蓝色。然后是蓝色，蓝色，蓝色，蓝色，蓝色，蓝色，蓝色，蓝色，蓝色，不会假装。完美的这些。我们完成了。就是现在。我是卡罗琳·肖（Caroline Shaw）。我是一名音乐家。我喜欢散步。我伴随着伟大音乐家生平的磁带长大，我妈妈有一个这样的盒子，她把它放在我们的微型面包车里，你知道的，挑一盘放进去，
that was how I learned about music. And one of those tapes was called Mr. Beethoven Lives Up Stairs. They would talk about him walking through the woods and hearing the birds and writing the sixth symphony. And that was kind of how I, for a long time, pictured what being a composer was. And recently I wrote a string quartet called The Evergreen after this very particular walk in the woods
这就是我了解音乐的方式。其中一盘磁带叫做《贝多芬先生住在楼上》（Mr. Beethoven Lives Upstairs）。他们会谈论他在树林里散步、听鸟儿歌唱并创作第六交响曲。在很长一段时间里，这就是我心中对作曲家的想象。最近我写了一首名为《常青》（The Evergreen）的弦乐四重奏，灵感来自于在树林里的一次非常特殊的散步
on an island off the west coast of Canada called Galeano Island. I just found myself kind of slowing down completely. I wasn't trying to like oh get to that turn point so you could go over here and then you see the vista and you see the view and that's the goal. I was like I don't really tear about the goal anymore. I just want to be here and listening and looking and I ended up seeing this beautiful evergreen tree that I wouldn't have seen if I had just been going towards what I wanted to go to and I just wrote a piece as like a little gift to this tree. I guess that makes me just like Beethoven, so you know. Our walks are a little different than what most people think about as walks. The reality is we don't actually walk in space. We float and we clam around with our fingertips mostly and just use our hands from ability.
在加拿大西海岸的一个叫加利亚诺岛（Galeano Island）的小岛上。我发现自己完全慢了下来。我不再试图去“哦，到达那个转折点，然后你可以去这里，然后你看到远景，你看到风景，那就是目标”。我当时想，我真的不在乎目标了。我只想留在这里，聆听和观察，我最后看到了一棵美丽的常青树，如果我只是直奔我想去的地方，我是绝对看不到它的，我写了一首曲子作为送给这棵树的小礼物。我想这让我就像贝多芬一样，所以你知道的。我们的散步与大多数人所认为的散步有点不同。现实情况是，我们在太空中并不真的走路。我们漂浮着，主要用指尖到处抓挠，主要用双手来获得活动能力。
This is NASA astronaut Drew Foistle and I'm here to talk to you about my very first space walk. What you see is the earth below you. That's it, you look between your feet and you see the tips of your toes and the blue planet, in our case over 300 miles beneath us and then the darkness, the blackness of space
这是美国宇航局宇航员德鲁·福斯特尔（Drew Feustel），我在这里向大家讲述我的第一次太空行走。你看到的是你下方的地球。就是这样，你看着你的双脚之间，看到你的脚趾尖和蓝色的星球，在我们的案例中，它在我们的脚下300多英里处，然后是黑暗，太空的黑漆漆一片
is set against that contrast. And one of the things that I always remember is thinking to myself, there's nothing out there. Earth is its own spaceship and we're all here alone and it's really a vulnerable place. And I don't think you really truly get the sense of that until you're staring at it from 300 miles up, watching it just float in nothing. It's incredible. ... you This story was brought to you by Poppet Magazine Productions. Written and produced by me, Haley Howell, with Anna Martin, Charlie Locke, Marin Cogan, and Maureen Tauy.
与这种对比相映衬。我永远记得的一件事是，心里想着，外面什么都没有。地球就是它自己的飞船，我们都孤单地待在这里，这真是一个脆弱的地方。我想，除非你从300英里高空凝视着它，看着它漂浮在一无所有之中，否则你真的无法真正体会到这一点。这太不可思议了。……这个故事由Poppet杂志制作公司为您呈现。由我，海莉·豪厄尔（Haley Howell）与安娜·马丁（Anna Martin）、查理·洛克（Charlie Locke）、马琳·科根（Marin Cogan）和莫琳·陶伊（Maureen Tauy）共同撰写和制作。
Our Managing Editor is Elise Craig. Our Executive Editor is Anita Baudigio. Our Editor in Chief is Doug McGregor. Music and Sound Design by Alex Overington. Annie Jen is our Art Director and Lauren Smith is Director of Operations. Researched by Cheetah Chamcheng, we had production help from Al Shatz and Andy Spillman, Ben Hickey did the episode art. Special thanks to third-angle music and Portland Oregon for letting us share their world premiere performance of Caroline Shaw's string quartet, The Evergreen.
我们的执行主编是伊丽丝·克雷格（Elise Craig）。我们的执行主编是安妮塔·波迪吉奥（Anita Baudigio）。我们的总编辑是道格·麦格雷戈（Doug McGregor）。音乐和声音设计由亚历克斯·奥伯林顿（Alex Overington）负责。安妮·詹（Annie Jen）是我们的艺术总监，劳伦·史密斯（Lauren Smith）是运营总监。由猎豹昌澄（Cheeta Chamcheng）进行研究，我们得到了阿尔·沙茨（Al Shatz）和安迪·斯皮尔曼（Andy Spillman）的制作帮助，本·希基（Ben Hickey）制作了分集插图。特别感谢第三角音乐（third-angle music）和俄勒冈州波特兰市让我们分享他们世界首演的卡罗琳·肖的弦乐四重奏《常青》。
performance of Caroline Shaw's String Quartet, the Evergreen. Special thanks also to Alexa Rose Miller at Arts Practica, Oscar Malina, Palestina, and all the fantastic folks we interviewed about walking, but weren't able to fit in this episode. This story was part of our fall issue. If you want to take a longer walk with us, an extended version of this episode is available for pop-up magazine members. Learn more and join us at pop-upmagazine.com. We will have an original in-house 99% visible for you next week. If you need more at 99PIs stories before then, we have a whole book about them. It's called the 99% visible city.
演奏了卡罗琳·肖的弦乐四重奏《常青》。还要特别感谢Arts Practica的亚历克斯·罗斯·米勒（Alexa Rose Miller）、奥斯卡·马利纳（Oscar Malina）、巴勒斯坦人以及所有我们采访过的关于步行、但未能塞进这一集的了不起的人们。这个故事是我们秋季刊的一部分。如果你想和我们一起进行更长的散步，流行杂志会员可以收听本集的扩展版本。了解更多并加入我们，请访问pop-upmagazine.com。我们下周将为您带来一个原创的内部99%隐形节目。如果您在此之前需要更多99PI的故事，我们有一整本关于它们书。它被称为《99%隐形城市》（The 99% Invisible City）。
It's a beautiful physical object. But if you want me to read it to you, we have an audio book available too. It's all at 99PI.org. Slashbook. Radio Tapio from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
它是一个美丽的实体物件。但如果你想让我读给你听，我们也有有声书。所有内容都在 99PI.org/book。来自 PRX 的 Radio Tapio。本集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。